welcome back one Professor blubbered
there's racism in your cupboard claiming
that a stocked Pantry can show the evils
of Jim Crow true tidy organized pantries
are popping up all over Tick Tock and
Instagram and so-called Pantry porn
posts say that five times really slow
you probably could actually a Loyola
marketing Professor argues that clean
well-stocked beautiful pantries are
actually bigoted quote What Lies Beneath
is a history of classist racist sexist
social structures influencers who
produce Pantry porn are predominantly
white women who demonstrated what it
looks like to maintain a nice home by
creating a new status symbol the
perfectly organized fully stocked pantry
so there you have it organized pantries
are now classist racist and sexist
especially if they're filled with
crackers now
[Applause]
yeah
we can still say the c word
not that one now what if you don't have
a pantry well you're racist too for
reasons we'll make up later
after all your lack of a pantry is
typical of white privilege why the need
to stock food when you can just take it
from black people
so does Professor Jenna drenton have a
point
I don't think so fact is some women will
say anything to avoid housework
I bet she's a real lazy Susan
ah my nose is running
anyway cat
we never had a lazy Susan when I was
growing up I was jealous of everybody
that had a lazy Susan you know the
little thing in the table that goes
around and around as a white supremacist
do you own a pantry
no a pantry is like a small room off the
kitchen yes I live in New York so my
kitchen is a small room that is also my
living room
the small room off your kitchen is your
bedroom yeah exactly
and that's a big step up for me it was
not that long ago that it was my kitchen
my bedroom my living room and my
bathroom
so no I by her logic I'm not a you know
I'm like a diversity educator really but
I I love that she said according to her
research yes the people who have these
organized pantries are white women and
I'm like
watching tick tocks of Fitness
influencers is research because she's
probably the same person who would
belittle anyone who said they did their
own research on coven narratives to be
like that's not research but you
watching tick tocks is all day like all
day that's research bro this is exot
like ridiculous like being a professor
is sounds kind of awesome you just say
whatever exactly you just all you gotta
do you know Kaylee uh it always I always
feel like now everything that they call
racist is an object or an activity that
one should aspire to yeah so being on
time is racist you know uh being being
just ambitious being wanting to be first
is racist now having something where you
can put your food is racist it's
ridiculous this woman needs to get a
life that caught my eye too when I saw
research like did student tuition pay
for this
research that I could demolish
single-handedly right here right now
because she says in order to be a ideal
mother ideal wife and ideal woman you
have to have this Pantry porn well I
must suck because my pantry is
ridiculous I debunk your theory right
here I mean I my pantry is a wreck yeah
and that that uh that is defined as
research according to her right yeah
that's all you have to do I'm your
researcher do you have a pantry David or
do you live in one
I have a cupboard that's how bad things
are
you have but you call it you tell the
girls who come over to Murphy bed
Murphy you know
Murphy's Law applies to my Murphy's bed
what can go wrong will
but
dense sometimes after a night of
drinking you wake up with a Murphy Brown
[Laughter]
that's all right
I don't remember what I was saying it's
there's the the yeah my pantry I don't I
mean what my kitchen looks like you know
in a movie when there's a divorce cop
and they want to make them look like
he's having a hard time yes
that's like what Mike I'll watch those
movies I'll be like Jesus that guy he's
got baking soda yeah
he's always drinking whiskey out of a
coffee mug yeah right he's pouring the
pouring the whiskey sits down he's
wearing a wife beater he's got he still
has a transistor radio it's 20 23.
that's who you are yeah but you can't
just as a side that you can't say wife
beater oh I know you have to like it's
you know but there's no actual name for
that shirt yeah like I went into
Nordstrom's I wanted to buy them yeah
and I didn't I had to Gusty it up I was
like do you have any um
spousal abusers
[Laughter]
they know what to say fantastic
all right Curtis you must have a very
strong opinion on this do you have a
pain I don't think you have a pantry
because you have 19 cats 18 cats I outdo
you uh cat yeah I have the one cat
because I'm a I'm a slob slabinski now
my wife keeps what they call a pantry we
live in 130 square foot apartment in the
upper west side right I do not know how
you do that you must be very carefully
yes very carefully so my job is she's
got all the Puss in Boots products for
the cats and I I have to change the
litter three times a day which means I
get a triple hernia every day but
there's one little portion for me that
proves I'm a racist I am a racist I
plead it I have my white bread my silver
cup white bread and my fluffle Nutter no
that is nothing why
[Music]
[Applause]
as charged wow you know what I find
interesting about this topic though
this is they take like an issue of class
okay they're talking about wealth and
status but they turn it into race and I
always try to figure out why do they do
that why is the left like the left are
afraid of any kind of class issues so
they paint it as race they should say
like you know pantries are a sign of
status and wealth just say that why do
you have to say rate and they're doing
this with everything
anyway too too serious no that was
really good oh thank you I was inspired
oh thank you Kaylee
you can stick around the rest of you get
yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else